[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
oh yeah it's another episode the podcast
oh I'm time now you know what I decided
to cut out is us introducing ourselves
each time it feels weird I know at this
point is if that if they already clicked
on and I like what's going on here who
or we introduced a guest we introduced a
guest
yeah let's just go right in yes Tim
welcome pressure for me to soon yeah are
you you expect in the rhythm of I'm
ready to roll with being put on the spot
I already how it was my audition am I
hired to yeah hop in we should have a
generic just like and later that we hit
a button Joe Tony trim so you could just
play that every time now the sample of
what you just did
[Music]
we got it we got it we got it we got it
welcome to the show
Sadie that's me
say sad 13 that's also me yeah yeah
welcome thank you good to see you too
the way nice to meet you yeah was funny
yeah Twitter do Twitter and in
spontaneity and me I South by Southwest
three years ago yeah and I was with my
buddy Rufio who's been on the show
before shoutout Rufio and and he got a a
text about a last minute drum gig you I
think you were looking for a drum gig oh
this friend got really hired he got a
text for last but it's wrong gig do it
and then for some reason I said I wanted
last-minute drum gig nobody hit me up it
was a weird way to go about thinking
about stuff just that level of an
entitlement but it worked out and so I
keep it and tweet it out I wanna drama
your band tomorrow in between the hours
of 11:00 a.m. and 2:00 p.m. and a few
people responded but you guys I think it
it looked like I don't know why I picked
that but I did it I'm so glad I was
nervous I was really nervous
you didn't want to do it I was about to
back out I know because it was the idea
of something we probably guilted you
know you didn't guilt me cuz you on
stage you couldn't get me okay but but I
sent like my manager at the time I was
like so I just had this tweet exchange
can you make sure this is real like yeah
we want to do this so I think
I think he was doing some similar
harassment of whoever you were working
at no it wasn't even it was just hot
soapy the time and I got there yeah and
then I saw that it was at the Mohawk
yeah it was so at the Mohawk yeah so I
get there I think before you I don't
know if you guys were on yet or was just
about the start now's thing I know like
meets rubbing their entire said oh no we
put you on for like the closer the
closer did the last song I didn't I
didn't know the songs I didn't expect
you to yeah and I for for you did fine I
hadn't watched a full video before we
watched it earlier Oh funny just a
critique my performance and I just
didn't I didn't do enough drumming you
know you know but sometimes you gotta
lay back yeah I was kind of space to the
song cuz it still felt like I felt like
I would say a trespasser but it just
felt yeah I have like a free jazz moment
yeah I just said so load out and just
wowed out there was just moments of the
song where on the 8th you just be like
yeah I was really excited just cuz it
was so it was it was really fun
experience because I had never done
anything like that so each time I did
something in a video you can see I'm
smiling time I was getting away with
something that each drum hit I was like
babe you drum performance yes your
reactions are funny too because you're
still trying to keep straight face and
do the song but you kept yeah yeah that
was fun for us didn't you but you played
like synth the next the next year I
place it
that was fun that coorg it was like the
mini Korg I was kind of like a Borg I
got in a zone on that I was I was on
Molly and several drinks in what you
want a friend micro so I was on that
thing and so is it there's a point where
I really got into a zone my fingers
which is free jazz i following yeah I
don't I don't know how much it
contributed to the song but my part if
you isolated it I was kind of getting it
in my fingers my fingers were we're
going kind of crazy
you had the sunglasses on he was like
this cuz he wasn't even looking at the
keys he was like here the sunglasses
Anya's doing okay damn okay that's a
preset yeah but thank you thank you for
allowing me to do that that was fun and
the unique experience I haven't drummed
on stage since what are you doing with
your life yeah that was a very promising
drum debut yeah I expected to see a lot
more percussion from you I mean you got
this you got a fake drum sounds good
we should've given you one of those you
gave me one of these yeah alright let's
talk about speedy Ortiz okay your bet
your other band my other band the one
time man I think I think someone changed
our Wikipedia wants to have you as a
former member yeah which is fair right
one time one time member sweetie Ortiz
I'm gonna like change it and like link
to this podcasts as evidence you're
writing it gonna clip this out well
nobody else to listen to the full full
thing we'll take this part out then
it'll be official boom that's it we go
you only got a play for the band wants
to be an official member and you got a
rip it oh I did that would be tricky
because we've had other people play on
this
that kind of became the song where
because on the record is from our first
record and it's like I would never do
this again
but it's the last song and it's like
eight it's like seven or eight minutes
long because we just didn't like a noise
jam for forever just spliced it down a
little bit so we'll what we do now I
hate to like talk to the audience from
the stage very like interact in any way
and I like to make the money at the
merch table so I leave the stage and
I'll give them my guitar during that
song to like whatever friend we have in
that city who plays music and I'll just
leave run of the merch be ready to sell
shirts to people who are trying to get
out early it sounds like time management
right there so there been a lot of
members of speedy Ortiz who've just
played for the outro possession yeah I
like your dedication to the merchant
you're like avoiding the people in the
audience and just the people who are
strong as hustle handing honey that's
like if I just put this mic down right
now and go sold some Molly on the corner
and came back you could I'm not stopping
you
I mean I guess it sort of works of
structure but inactivity that's a weird
analogy it's like before you got paid
for selling the Molly in your other
pocket you have a t-shirt and you're
like pay me for this one first
well that's maybe the okay closer
analogy to what I do what what are
alternate names for speedy ortiz or
ditch i'll just land on that it's
alright a list o whiteboard and start
scratching stuff out with their big
debates it started as a solo project
okay so it was just the name that i
typed in to like garage band when I was
bouncing stuff it's a character from
loving rocket it's the comic book that's
sure it's like a great long-running punk
comic that set in California yeah one of
my favorite favorite favorite comics and
the character does it interact in the
black pant the world at all because I
know it's not if you talk about comics
right now
thing else goes definitely in like the
indie comic drone although I'm sure they
love Black Panther so the character
speedy Ortiz dies and there's an issue
called the death of speedy Ortiz that
has his sister and friends and like
would-be girlfriend just kind of
grieving in these different ways and I
had my roommate had Pat I had a lot of
the young friends pass away in the year
before starting the project and I was
kind of like coping with it through
writing this like solo record that I was
home recording so that was just the name
that I went with yeah
when I became a band I was like why did
I why did I choose this like it's not a
if you're into like indie comics it's
not obscure but to like 95% of people
like yeah they're like oh is it Speedy
Gonzales like so why not slow Sanchez
yeah I get that
oh yeah oh wow I guess I'm just very
unoriginal person that's what I came
here to tell you today this is an
interview tell me I'm gonna tell you
I've heard before so that's why it's
called speedy earth if you're this
before that's good how's that make you
feel like I should make it my ringtone
yeah alright yeah
clip that up pay post-production clip
that up send it to Sadie's email yeah
bada-bing bada-boom do a clean one here
[Music]
better answer the phone
so you are at the merch table after
shows yeah are there instances where
you're at the merch table and you have
an interaction and you say I shouldn't
be at the merch table right now yeah we
we developed like a code if I got
someone being a little too little too
much you mean is that we meant fine yeah
like a safe word yeah um well I feel
like I shouldn't will this change this
we've been doing is um I'll send a text
to someone and it's the the safe phrase
now is that I'm looking for my inhaler
that's a good one asthma and that um
like my bandmate well because I also
merch my bandmates will pack stuff down
and whatever go have a drink and if I
text them like yo looking for my inhaler
they'll come up to me and be like hey
did you need to get your inhaler like I
can handle merch whoever's creeping me
out will then have to deal with with a
man yeah yeah that's good yeah that's
like oh I need to find my weed because
then everyone's gonna be like oh good
exactly that's the last thing I want to
get out of that but I try I mean
sometimes I try to like have it be like
a teachable moment if someone's being
weird at the merch table you can like
gauge it sometimes people just don't get
that you don't want to be touched
without permission
oh so you'll just like be like go into
take they'll be like can I take a photo
and they'll go to take a photo and they
do the armory on the way so I'm like hey
I want to take the photo but just so you
know like you got to ask people before
you touch them I'd rather we just take
the photo I call it the entitled selfie
yeah but they don't like I don't know I
gave people too much credit maybe but
I'm just like no one's told them this
before so maybe me telling them will
make a difference for the next person
they ask to take a pill honest I respect
that Eugene so I try you're changing the
world one douche bag at a time it gets
bad I'm looking for the inhaler yeah
thank you I got a question for you yeah
you know it's tax season right now and I
was doing my taxes oh and you know
you're a traveling musician such as
myself
what's what's your what's your biggest
write-off
I don't do my taxes I mean someone does
them for me but do you get do you write
off everything like we can write off
dinners yeah we can write off any food
that we do on tour any gear any like
computer stuff so you can buy a six
thousand dollar guitar and just write it
off I think there's like an extent I
think there's a limit yeah but um I'm
pretty sure that things technically
become lost years often because yeah
writing off stuff you get those gigs I
don't know what you're talking about
yeah above it above board yeah I write
I'm a [ __ ] maniac with your and
everything I write off everything what's
the weirdest thing you've had to write
off ah let's see well you know most of
the time the rooms are paid for so that
I'll just like ball out on the minibar
and stuff and then make it look like I
paid for the room yeah but really that's
smart I never think to do that all day
you know I paid for this room son but
then can't you write off food while
you're working - yeah 25% Oh see I
didn't notice Lupo
why do I have a like she why do we have
business people they're not teaching me
dude
look this is what you don't eat the
government that's what you do you get
that you get the business card and you
only use it for when you're out of town
doing shows and you only use that card
and then at the end of the year is so
easy you just take that whole statement
oh yeah just put it down pam pam pam
give me my money
Uncle Sam give me mom gimme give it give
it give it back I want my [ __ ] back hey
give me my [ __ ] Sam that are these taxes
[ __ ] is wet it's a move to Texas or move
to Texas when you get a discount on
taxes it's not real yeah they don't have
state tax so if you move there your [ __ ]
will be sort of mess
[Music]
Illinois has a high tax rate so does New
York and Cali Oregon has no sales tax
yes yeah I go if I've got to do like a
big Guitar Center trip I'll Drive to
Delaware that's what you do that's what
you do you go there and you buy if
you're gonna buy a car just go across
the board yeah get it over there bring
it right back a car that's a lot of
sales tax on a car seriously yeah yeah
pro tips
you got a new album coming out yeah yeah
is that is the is the rollout to an
album is that a stressful time for you
um the press part and press today yeah
this is like the first day of stuff I've
had to do mm-hmm we did all the like
this is the longest we've taken or
release an album so it's normally more
stressful I didn't want it to be
stressful like it normally is where you
have like two months to get all the
videos done all the photos done and yeah
are you on a different label same label
yeah
same label more experience yeah record
with them yeah they're called carpark
records carpark records out of DC okay
okay indie label who else they got on
there
mmm Tory mom Oh
[Music]
I mean a lot of people know some of
their like older acts like they had Dan
Deacon peach house for a while deacons -
[ __ ] now they have um Skyler Spence
cloud nothing well they're pretty
reputable yeah and
like nice people you got like a good way
of doing business
yeah no it's just like for people and I
know them all and they're all very nice
and they gave me an imprint actually I
put out a record yep yes I got my own
little label now no milk belly have you
heard them
I haven't get them on here milk belly
with an e B and E okay belly yeah
regular style belly a widow
regular style listen out is a spell like
Billie but pronounced like belly is is
belly like the movie yeah yeah have you
seen belly have seen belly how many
times this was like once and a half
wasn't a half yeah how many times have
you seen belly once and then parts in
passing on television yeah exact same
mmm so milk belly from Chicago first
band of released yeah record by I like
that milk belly they're cool they're
weird yeah what kind of music
they're like so the they really like
like lightning bolt like a I bet they
love like Jesus lizard but the singer
kind of sounds like um it sounds a lot
like the breeders so it's like heavy
weird kind of almost like proto metal
sometimes arty but it's very like cool
like voice that can really carry a weird
melody man I was at I was at a Jesus
Lizard show once yeah and the guy who
was crowd started the lead singer David
you know I was crowd surfing and he lost
his wedding ring oh no crowd surf right
so what people must have helped him out
well yeah he stopped the show and he was
like oh yeah we got we gotta stop a loss
but my wedding ring oh so then the whole
crowds on their feet look on their knees
looking for this ring yeah and then
someone about it and then the show got
even more laughs I would lose it I've
been so upset the jesus lizard is an
incredible band to Cielo
there's a YouTube video of them he's
going crazy I don't know where a bottle
flies across the crown hits the dude in
the back of the head he hits the ground
glass everywhere he's bleeding and [ __ ]
yeah he said you didn't get my other
side [ __ ] and then and then he's
like bang goes right he goes right back
into it
damn the guy yeah look there's so many
stories about the guy he's a Chicago
legend yeah yeah he's a [ __ ] madman
one of my heroes I couldn't take that
right somebody throw something on a
state actually in Philly a couple years
ago we were doing Eric Andre show live
and it was towards the very end almost
at the very end somebody threw a bottle
of something on stage from the balcony
and I couldn't and I i stuck near you it
almost I think it hit me I think it
definitely did yeah hit me because if it
doesn't got thrown up there I wouldn't
have been mad you get hit me and I start
I started running around a venue into
the balcony who the hell threw that I
don't know what my mango was you expect
justice throw that [ __ ] at Eric yeah
yeah throw it at Erika's he you funny
because when you be doing themselves man
I'll see you like when it starts getting
crazy I could just see you creeping
creeping yeah this point sweet brings a
bunch of people onstage and then and
then I start dipping back okay let me
let y'all finish the second window in
the when the ranch starts getting
sprayed everywhere yeah it's a bit it
can be you know what was your craziest
performance this one way you said this
[ __ ] this is going cuz something I'll
have a show where I'll be doing well and
I'll do a couple bits and this bit is
good but it ain't that good oh they're
just people are having it like a wild
times just a bunch of common factors I'm
sure I can't probably remember the
specific
but I feel like every Chicago show is
like that yeah and I feel that every
time I'm there cuz like their cities you
hit on tour where you know it's like a
drinking City but maybe it's not gonna
go well like I've had some bad times in
like Fargo Fargo multiple bad times
people like to drink and they like to
drink a little too much like some of my
merch table horror stories are in Fargo
Chicago will play a show it's sold out
anything I say it's like not funny but
people are like cheering between song
bats it yeah like I don't like to talk
really and yet they love it and then at
the end of the night you think like
people are that drunk and rowdy like
they're gonna be horrible to deal with
and everyone is so respectful and nice
and like anyone I talk to it merch is
just like a sweet person so Chicago is
one of my favorite places to play for
that reason because it's like sometimes
the high energy is you it's like a trade
like you're just gonna have to deal with
horrible people at merch but I don't
feel that that's true in Chicago
I noticed that too like a lot of when
there's band called Pelican that one of
my friends is in it and I've seen them
play in multiple cities I saw them in
Berlin and it was the craziest show
everyone's [ __ ] going nuts but every
time they play in Chicago which I've
seen so many times everyone just really
calm in their heads but it's sold out
yeah you know they kill it but it's just
yeah it's you're right it is more of
like a calm just kind of like drunken
having a good time yeah but they're not
like shouting horrible [ __ ] yeah and
they're not getting to lit no yeah have
you botched the show before before being
so drunk are you pretty hmm not in so
long but I mean I come from like playing
and punk houses and like basements and
stuff like that so I'm sure there were
some house shows that I I remember like
being young and showing up to house show
with like a whole Hansel of whisky that
was like my drink for the night so I'm
sure I remember like playing a show like
Montana or some
and we played like two shows that night
when was it a VFW hall one person came
and then we play a crazy house party
after where people were just like naked
and I was drinking my whiskey and I'd
remember playing the whole show just
like in a corner and then I just stopped
remembering at some point in the set
like me facing a corner
well you faced away from the crowd
because you didn't want to look at them
when you was just so I thought it was
cool or something yeah
but that's long ago that's what a while
remember the guy from The Strokes used
to do that he did yeah he would just he
would turn away from the audience and
sing towards the band that's cool you
know that was his thing I like when the
band
I like when um you know the band's like
facing each other and cheating out a
little bit like a semicircle I always
enjoy watching people play that way with
each other but we don't do that we're
just like boring you know why we just do
the regular yeah you know we had a
shtick you know a simple bit of
stagecraft I enjoy his when is two
performers I either rapper to sing or a
cup of rappers onstage and it's a big
stage and when they both cross and go to
opposite sides of the stage Farooq
assaulted that if the other night yeah
just a simple yes yeah now you go over
there now imma go over here I would
never even think to do that it blew my
mind you get that side and I'll get this
side and I did that on stage once it was
a Chappelle instead Graham as he did is
in me and Michael che and we were all
kind of riffing on stage and it was just
a longer conversation and it's so uh I
crossed and then Mike didn't cross
because we left Dave in the middle
Michael suppose he's like what are you
doing I'm like
he's supposed to cross man like a rap
show he's supposed to mix this [ __ ] up
you know what I'm saying that's a kid in
place yet yeah hey Sadie Sadie where
were you wait what were you when you
heard race River blackbeetles for the
first time probably on tour you'll - I
feel like I'd been texted about it for
days yeah it was like I guess I should
guess I should check this out you
checked it out I did did you enjoy the
falsetto part yeah how could you not
I liked your rendition just now so you
mentioned before we were doing the
interview
so you went several assault which I
didn't even know the moment I landed
went straight from the airport to the
show they played for two and a half
hours I can't even imagine I didn't even
know Veruca Salt at a catalog that long
and they they left stuff out it's not
like they played every song there were
hits that I was looking for two and a
half hours yeah yeah it was there a
point in that show where you're just
like it's time to wrap it up mother I
was exhausted because I I mean I go to
bed like I'm in bed if I'm you know in
an ideal world before midnight Eastern
Time
yeah so I had left Philly I got to the
airport like 2:30 I landed close to 9:00
was at the show at 9:30 and then two and
a half hours of music so I was like
sitting on the floor at some point back
together a few years but they are doing
a tour in Australia I think somehow for
the first time which is baffling to me
because I would have assumed they went
over there in the 90s but I think they
haven't been there before so they were
trying to do a practice show of like
most of their catalogs so they can
figure out you do that yeah well they
talked about the empty bottle and I was
uh I was
happy I like the bottle how do you how
do you feel about this Smashing Pumpkins
reunion addy read Darcy's yeah yeah I
love other people's band drama so I
don't really care for I mean I like to
smash my words when I was younger yeah I
think that Billy Corgan is just like a
nightmare
what an amazing writer musician but yeah
what Alex Jones in for some cool tunes
nothing he tried to get the Smashing
Pumpkins back together without any of
the original member I know nobody wants
that it was a disaster yeah and I'm you
know I'm surprised that james iha is
doing it I am too but even without Darcy
I think I'm gonna go to that show you
are miss Paul yeah so much listen I
would go for free Hannibal you ought
Smashing Pumpkins fan not like that
yeah I know that they did well you know
that today is the greatest you had to
give me you gotta know despite all my
rage
I'm still just a rat in the cage is one
of those song I don't think giving them
their full the full vibe but a song song
but I'm sure they have a few songs that
yeah I know the song that's there that's
one of their hits I just played yeah
that's how that's what it sounds like
it's exactly how it sounded like yeah
yeah we did a perfect rendition except
he's like it's bad like that's how
that's his vocal quality he's got a very
unique voice anyway you know what's your
favorite pumpkins Siamese Dream by far I
like melancholy really yeah even like as
it is but I know there's a sport where
people will try to condense it down to
one good album rather than a ridiculous
double album it was ridiculous but you
know what I think that was a business
move because back then if you sold
double albums they were considered
selling two albums yeah yes
record sales double off with one album
and then you were riding off of a hit
album already alright why not probably
riding on some other stuff too and that
was that's the the current music sales
equivalent equivalent is that the stream
and the stream so acts will put 24 25
tracks on a release because then all
those dreams count towards number to get
you and then a reissue like within the
same year with like five more songs 24
song Jesus Christ not a song but maybe
if you just say you want to just listen
to two hours of me goes then you set but
see you from that punk rock era so it'd
be like 30 songs but each song would be
like a minute and a half yeah that was
great
I like that I loved that William in
misfits yeah yeah good I like I don't
like songs that gets you long if it's
longer than four minutes I don't always
understand why absolutely just give me a
good short cut the fat let's get to the
point song and they don't they don't
write it out they just didn't fun oh you
see you're a punk drummer now will you
write in the song do you come up with
the title first and then do a song or do
you do a song and entitle it I'm like so
terrible at writing titles so it's
always changing until the last minute
yeah and it's still never good like I
don't think any of my other ones do you
have any pets or children well you have
any pets or children I got a doggy so
how long did it take for you to come up
with a name for that dog I didn't name
him yet he's a he's a rescue you didn't
your dog doesn't have a name he has a
name but it came from the shelter oh so
he was a state job done I fostered him
his name was Buster Buster I like
fostered rather than rescue
well I adopted him ultimately adopted I
borrow it for a little bit and then
rescue unless it was in front of a
speeding bus
that's a risk it just means that you
didn't get it from LaBrie derp yeah it's
just the term that you use to make
yourself feel better about yourself and
to encourage other people I mean I have
I have a dog that I adopted yeah I never
say are you rescued her from the
anti-cruelty risk did you well I mean I
got it from the anti-cruelty but it's a
great dog I would have bought the dog
what kind of dog is she she's some kind
of a shepherd mix cool she cool as [ __ ]
and I but yeah you're right I don't like
that whole that that that that Hewitt
the heroic vibe of just like I rescued
it he's right you know would you put on
a [ __ ] cape I wouldn't say that I
rescued the dog but he came from
they found him like he was homeless in I
think South Carolina and he had really
bad mange and so his whole here's a
puppy but his whole like forehead was
scabbed over he was blind he like he
looked like he and looked too good
no got that laser gone on he it just
healed up when you know he was like
being fed and not homeless
and he wasn't buying anymore no cuz he
just had scabs over his eyes he wasn't
actually it just was so bad that he
couldn't open his little puppy eyes he
at this point is he's gotta be turning
eight this year so I got him he was like
four months when I got him but so I mean
obviously I didn't rescue him but
whoever got him they go because there's
so many especially pitbulls and like
also lose yeah so in the South they just
go straight to kill shelters and no one
wants them yes I was rescues because the
places you know usually in like New York
my guys sweet so I tried to change his
name and one that I did adopt him and
wasn't I fostered him and then it wasn't
there was no way I was gonna give him
back um I tried to call him fry fry cuz
he's he's got like a little kind of
light red spots so like fry from
Futurama I bet
just like eating some fries and life and
probably I was like like no you start
some weed some fries like you popcorn
yeah oh that's a good dog names oh
that's a great dog they're like a little
poodle thing yeah popcorn so I tried to
change his name he was not feeling it
he's buster yeah you you think there's
any dogs out that name Ulysses that's a
good dog
Lizzie's like a mastiff you good yeah
yeah I could see that
I like when dogs have human names just
like me to Dave I like that you know
what no I had a dog named Dave I've
heard some closer ones I had got a
homing with a Dave dog he rest in peace
Dave but it was a beagle and his name
was Dave and he was cool I'm not
actually he was kind of a dick but it
was it was a good dog yeah it was a good
dog but he just he just wasn't he got he
got to a point where he was old and he
would just take food off the table one
time he got into a plate full of edibles
oh that happened to my dog once well
yeah as he didn't change him did he
change them like in the long term we
heard dogs
some dogs they'll ingest some weed and
then the second Buster hasn't been the
same again yeah he was okay but I was
very it's the most I've been scared for
him it was like someone was in my house
that I didn't know had like cookies or
something in their backpack and I came
back to my house and was like what is
this like trash on the floor and I
realized that he'd eaten something I was
like what was that is that chocolate
like if so he has to go to the vet and
they were like oh my god no it's like
very strong weed cookies or 50
milligrams so I gave him I was the
weekend so the vet close to me I lived
in like Western Mass at the time so it's
not easy to get to like an animal
hospital the vets close to me we're all
closed so I gave him the stuff to make
him throw up he did I was like well he's
probably fine and like two hours later
he's running in circles but like one
side of his body is going a little
faster than the other side he seemed
weird like running across
the room really fast with his mouth all
out and then this lying down to sleep
like watching him to hospital when he
woke up and was doing that and they put
him I was crying I was like he's gonna
die and they thought it was very funny
because the second he got there other
dogs who are there for the weekend or
howling and he starts like singing along
yeah they're like he's singing in the
drunk tank so they put him on like a
charcoal to absorb all the sorrow so
thank you I guess they put charcoal
intravenously yeah cuz it so except the
drugs also that's what is't taking from
so we can offer oh yeah that's our coal
charcoal if you drank too much you don't
want to be hungover yeah take some
charcoal pills I got some soccer fields
in my back now you know BAM
it's our coke pills we got a new sponsor
I think yeah just go to the store a buy
bag of charcoals and then eat charcoals
I mean I don't but one cuz you know like
that's what I mean the bar yeah Oh like
what they use for fish tanks and [ __ ]
human grade oh so y'all
oh you're bringing the charcoal charcoal
is charcoal can't wait
charcoal pills did you pick that up at
Ross's there you go I'll see what's in
also get this before this yeah act oh oh
okay I've seen activated yeah you can't
use like the charcoal from your grill
it's for gas doesn't digest it basically
soaks up anything in your stomach so you
don't want to take it forget anytime
near when you took medicine you need or
like food that you want to actually
digest but um if you ate some food that
maybe you're a little allergic to or you
just like had too much to drink
farting a lot or when you're farting
what you want to soak up that gas into
charcoal pill it's just charcoal Sadie
you said your dog has a bald patch of
his for it you should get him a tattoo
like 21 savage hands oh yeah like that
yeah
a little some different yeah a safe
ethical doggy tattoo I don't know they
thethe a tattoo doggies I think yeah
just to like identify them when they do
they do it the inside if you adopt the
greyhound and it's got numbers in it
that means it was a race dog or if you
want to be really shameless about show
business you could tattoo speedy Ortiz
Loco something on that start people love
dogs on Instagram yeah you could really
yeah I'll post him sometimes mmm the
first shirt I ever I I made for us when
I still like would make the shirts
myself in like my bathroom with a
silkscreen was I drew Buster like
looking at pouring but it wasn't like
obvious he was looking at porn he's just
like looking at a laptop but he's got
that look on his face that it's a dog
looking at porn you know he's been in
our before you know what I do with my
Instagram stories my dog is real cool
about putting glasses on her head put
glasses on her face she'll just like
chill and just less and the averages are
Wow's out anything on there but she'll
just like just look at me and be like so
like I'll do Instagram stories what kind
of glasses you put on I'll put on just
like specs like nice glasses and then I
do this voice where I'm just like can
you find some I hear dog in here some
free trade coffee and then like he's
she's got the you know I'll do like her
voice yeah dude he's Instagram do a
series of Instagram stories with that
that's very people get a kick out of it
I didn't maybe I've just heard you
describe it and I'm getting a kick out
of it you know so follow me baby Tony
trim on our jeans my first order of
business when we baby what's the last
concert you've been to yeah there's a
Museum of surgery in Chicago have you
heard his place no and
well one of the exhibits is this guy
Frederick something Weiss
who was a doctor that noticed that a lot
of babies were dying during didn't when
it was being delivered and so he found
that he was because the doctors were
touching cadavers and then without
washing their hands they were delivered
babies so there were a lot of deaths and
so he said how about y'all start washing
your hand yeah so that's how like hand
washing hygiene but doctors yet because
of cadavers killing babies because
somebody would go operate on a cadaver a
dead body and then bring over the
disease it's a new I'm glad they figured
that one it'll be hard as all the other
doctors like you're crazy there's no way
how no way and the guy was like no this
is what's happening like there was an
actual argument about it and it took a
while for them to be like oh okay yeah
and they like didn't embalm bodies then
the way they do now that's like a much
more recent development that isn't
really necessary or good for the
environment at all bombing bodies yeah
it's terrible yeah yeah I think you
should just let it let it rot naturally
some states don't it's not legal they
require you to know it's legal to embalm
and to cremate but they won't let you
have like a green um burial that's crazy
yeah that's what you get cremated I
would be cremated or I would do the like
green burial which i think is cool was
it well they have a thing now that I
don't know if it's just like a prototype
but it's like a suit that's made of
mushrooms that eat flesh so you go in
the ground in this these mushrooms in
there fed on you and that grows like
plants that's the one where they turn
how many plants though I need my [ __ ]
you want to be like the most plants it
won't be a good amount of plants I don't
want to be just like a [ __ ] patch of
greens of some
they know you don't know like just what
six sunflower trees I mean want to be
some spruces yeah pomegranate juice yeah
I saw one where the orange tree well
they turned you into a tree where they
like put your body into this sack and
then they put it somehow it's tied to
like a sapling and then like it the
sapling feeds off of you
the first whatever years so like you're
literally being turned into a tree
I think that's dope because I think
that's cool yeah because we need more
trees and it's caught like to be
cremated
it's I just I just finish this book
today so I got all the facts handy
tomorrow I won't remember but it's the
same as taking like a 500 mile car trip
to be cremated it's like a huge
expenditure of energy and so some people
are also like alternate alternative
death movement they'll use like
crematoriums to power of their public
resources like like like public swimming
pools that are heated with like the
excess heat permanent crematoriums so
that's there's some stuff going down in
the world of death I wonder if I could
be super duper frozen and then just like
yeah nitrogenous yeah just super fro
light like [ __ ] like when you shatter
and shattered completely nitrogen and
then just throw you that's it that's a
piece one of my biggest fears is being
burned alive hmm that is that's so
terrifying to me to just be like I bet
you going to shock pretty quick and it
doesn't feel yeah
or B or like oh I guess freezing the
death would be a lot worse but I think
you get really calm really you may be
both like you breathing sounds better
than fire to me you so you'd rather
freeze the death and burn to death
mmm yeah I think so what about you
Hannibal
freeze to death
really cuz it seems like you just kind
of slow down you're blasting the shining
it's so uncomfortable you're cool and
you know what even worse you might have
like a favorite watch or some type of
thing on and you got to see that burn
with you like oh man I'm burning in my
flight [ __ ] this gotta burn with me not
that I have any use for it whereas if
you're freezing I think your your brain
thinks you're actually overheating so
you start stripping and like so you just
be throwing away your watch I heard
about that you just be like I don't need
this material [ __ ] so maybe it's
really enlightening - I love those
stories about I love those stories about
it's like like a cowboy
it was riding his horse and he got a
real coal and then he had to kill his
horse and open them up just as they are
well that's some Star Wars [ __ ] - that
happened to Star Wars it's like a
episode because the tauntaun doesn't
smell good seem not the biggest fan yeah
this is cool this is the only time I've
been talking to two men who knew less
about Star Wars than me get off reddit
girl any expert
[Music]
what's the name of new album don't read
first script twerp verse verse I thought
you say squirt burst brace that's the
remix album that's a crazy one hey I'm
not gonna make up titles I should have
called it squirt verse white rose maybe
squirt verse hey spit a squirt verse
exactly squirt verse I didn't what
squirt is it Pete was it something else
related to pee blue sea squirt squirt
verse it's all pee anyway it's all about
that what is squirt its squirt pee I
think they determined it's like 70% pee
[Music]
one time she didn't tell me squirt
hold on one time she didn't tell me that
she squirted I was down there and I got
[ __ ] murder overflow my own personal
damn right
[Music]
and I know you thought that's it coming
I like that that sounds like a robot
squirrel be kind of Valley original
Jumanji sound like a chef the recent I
haven't seen the remake yeah I saw it
it's a fun family movie
I was with my wait yeah nephews and my
brother saw Jumanji
9 or 10 deep it's good
wait is that the one with the rock in it
yeah and Kevin Hart yep black
star-studded cast for Jumanji yes it's a
fun movie is it like a sequel to the
original Jumanji or just to remain just
a remake
okay or is it different like people all
together playing the same game yeah
Ksenia oh it's good yeah I remember the
board game yeah so it's a great
children's book that I remember having
as a kid but the original movie scared
that I remember being so scared of it
and it must have come out what like 95
something like that so I'm like 7 years
old and I remember I had seen a Jason
movie the same year which I was probably
too young to see Jason movie didn't
upset me Jumanji gave me nightmares for
like the rest of the year what was so
terrifying about Jumanji there's like
poison snakes there's like drowning it's
just like everything that could possibly
go wrong if you found yourself in a
jungle ok they really [ __ ] me up yeah
I always wondered it's good kids see
movies uh early on I had a friend he had
a his daughter was two or three at his
army in the
said yeah her favorite movie is 300
[Laughter]
artem young I remember Watson
Kindergarten Cop and you know it was I
feel like it was marketed as a
children's movie but there was some bark
[ __ ] going on in there people getting
killed drunk bills yeah stuff like that
I just saw boss baby
boss boss baby it's like yeah where's
that global money war Alec Baldwin plays
a boss baby and that's the plot that's
like what but I don't know who that like
I I didn't think I'd like it and I do
enjoy it
I don't know who that movies for well
cuz I think it's for children but
there's jokes about HR there's no I'm
like who
well HR Human Resources yeah see you had
that like you think a little kid going
to see the latest DreamWorks movie but
they knew that these but these movies
throw jokes like that in there for the
adults just so that those can be like
hey I don't have to [ __ ] watch Barney
then like the Lego movies just heavy
slick [ __ ] crazy wrote that uh Lord was
the last name with one of the producers
and somebody else I don't know where I
don't know who wrote it with those it's
this super fast face yeah well you miss
a lot of jokes watching it I saw my
first lego movie for the first time not
too long ago it was the Ninjago one yeah
okay yeah I only saw I don't really
enjoy regular lego movie yeah jack it
isn't as good as the Batman want
yeah you know you know what I you know I
didn't like about it was a Jackie Chan
his his you could you you Jack it first
of all Jackie chance doesn't have a good
grasp on the English language he's in a
movie he's in the movie he does the
voiceover for like the sensei but you
could tell like his English is like
forced so you can understand them and it
just doesn't feel natural there's no
personality he's not a good voiceover
actor yeah because it's forced like you
could tell you it's trained and forced
into saying you know but like Jackie
Chan's English is horrible if you listen
to him talk sounds like yeah it doesn't
sound good so I was like I'd rather just
see him doing like the martial arts
stuff that he's really good at you know
yeah that was that just being racist to
myself you know you think he's like you
know okay good not charismatic as a
voice actor yeah but you enjoy his work
but I enjoy his work as a yeah as a
stuntman he's playing people who are
great voice actors who I would not want
to watch and yeah I don't want it yeah I
don't want to hear somebody that doesn't
have a grasp on a language do voiceover
work for that language that's that's
counterproductive yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
fired
[Music]
Jackie Chan please don't kick my hands
you have aspirations to write a book I'd
wrote I wrote a book you got a book yes
I shouldn't say a book I'll have a book
out sometime oh you 101 all right it's
done it's done nice but it's poetry
so it's boring do you when you're
writing poetry and putting it out you're
on the rest of people do you make it
what am I trying to add like the way
this is the way you would say it the way
you would say might be differently
didn't have somebody read instead I feel
like you have more control over it
because the line breaks are so
particular yeah so do you that's a
that's not that's uh poetry used to be
such a staple in every culture do you
feel like now that it's kind of a dying
art I think there's a lot of like slam
poets that are extremely popular like
right now yeah that's a slam poetry I
thought the time well it's funny like so
I went to write before
originally right when I started speedier
to use I went to grad school for poetry
and I got a teaching gig at the
University and I was teaching writing
and every week I'd let the kids like
bring in something they liked and we'd
all talk about it as a class and like
what is the value of this text for the
public kind of try to analyze it it
could be anything they would bring in
like clips from community they would
bring in and they would bring in like
slam poets on YouTube and so there's I
didn't I kind of had the same thought
you did like I hadn't really thought
about slam poetry since like 1998 but
because when we were in college it was
it was big people it's big again but
people it's very different and it's a
lot on YouTube and then they'll
like three books I read this year three
books I read this year all this
publisher button poetry and I just got
the books because I had you know seen
the poems online and read them and I
realized after they're all like insta
famous for their slam poetry so I think
it's a big I mean do you do like open
mics no I'm not like or like I don't
even know I'll do readings but like I'm
not I'm definitely not a slam performer
I'm probably not a good reader but I
have a bug okay but I think yeah shall
we promote the book now cuz it's not
it's not yes not it comes out in
November you're gonna say that I'm doing
about this year you would read well it's
funny it's some of my poetry friends
from grad school would use to actually
just do stand-up and I'd see them do
stand-up and then we'd be in workshop
and they were just like they're stand-up
routine is written out like as a poem
and workshopping that yeah it's funny so
how did it go when you do stand there
well sometimes but sometimes they would
kind of heckle and [ __ ] it would get
weird though but I enjoy because it
would be less comedians there so here's
more of a little competition exactly
yeah and also with comedians that are
with Mike they're sometimes working on a
set nobody isn't that a bunch of people
yeah they wouldn't go on vs. poets
adjust their performer but there is
different I mean what we used to do my
open mic back in southern Nepal you were
the you were the only comic we never had
honestly out of all those sessions that
we had we never had one comic except for
you you were the only one knew somebody
else - I was
they was there who I don't cuz I don't
remember okay but for the most part it
was you it was you it was Hannibal's the
comic guy and then we had eighty rappers
he Rosa Dave the guidance operating the
camera went to college was too and he he
thought yeah but they we would have all
kinds of people that do like they do
acting gigs they'd be like they do a
scene from Hamlet saying
Sadie say to use of a pleasure talking
because it's fun thank you for having me
this is great I can't wait to get the
band back together this is a good bet
this is a good yeah I think we have good
chemistry and I'm ready to give up the
guitar for this band right okay
compatible wants to end the episode
awkwardly solvers yeah
[Music]